a very good evening a secret settlement
between prince andrew's accuser virginia
dufrey and the convicted pedophile
jeffrey epstein has been made public
prince andrews lawyers say the document
which was drawn up in 2009 releases him
from any liability mr frey claims that
she was trafficked by epstein to have
sex with the prince when she was age 17
a minor under u.s law prince andrew has
denied all the allegations made against
him our correspondent joe pike joins us
now from new york with the latest so joe
what have you gleaned from the documents
well done there is no mention of prince
andrew or of royalty no specific
mention in this nine page
unsealed document but there is an
important provision which i'm sure his
lawyers may argue gets him out of this
case a provision to protect quote other
potential defendants from liability but
it is a very uh broad
clause here a very broad clause which
may mean that the judge tomorrow lewis
kaplan decides to go ahead with this
case ultimately prince andrew has for
many months have been attempting to get
this case thrown out the last attempt
was based on on a point of jurisdiction
the duke of york's lawyers arguing
virginia dufrey lives in australia she
may be a u.s citizen but has not lived
in the u.s for much of the last 20 years
and therefore this should be thrown out
they rejected it now it's up to judge
lewis kaplan yet again to decide on
another argument now this is a half a
million dollar settlement signed by
virginia du frey and the pedophile
jeffrey epstein in
2009
and as i say a prince andrew's lawyers
will be hoping that the provision this
broad provision to protect other
potential defendants may help them
however
uh what uh whatever the judge decides uh
certainly we could be seeing uh problems
for him in the future partly because
wherever this court decides the court of
public opinion has been uh has delivered
a pretty a brutal verdict on the duke of
york certainly after that damaging a
news night interview in 2019 also the
fact that here last week gala maxwell a
close friend of his uh was convicted of
child sex trafficking offences that
means of course the two close friends
friends of prince andrew
people who invited to ban more people
invited to windsor castle are now we
know jeffrey epstein
a uh prolific paedophile and gala
maxwell a child sex trafficker if the
judge decides to go ahead with this and
that this document released today does
not change that we could see a jury
trial in the autumn of this year now
trials are very rare in civil proceeding
this is a civil proceeding which means
it's about money and reputation not
about potential prison time now trials
are rare because normally parties settle
they decide often with a financial
incentive to
sign out of court and not proceed to a
trial the difference here is that
virginia dufrese
who accuses
prince andrew of sexually assaulting her
three times when she was 17 years old he
of course denies that
her motives are slightly different she
already has a significant amount of
money she lives quite a
uh a wealthy lifestyle in australia
partly from the compensation in this
deal with jeffrey epstein half a million
dollars from 2009 that may mean she
would potentially decide it's not about
the money she'd prefer to pursue justice
and find the truth whatever is offered
by prince andrew and his lawyers but of
course that has not happened prince
andrew has not tried to settle yet and
that may not happen the document is out
he does not mention prince andrew by
name but there is a broad provision that
could potentially
protect defendants
like him we will have a hearing in this
case tomorrow in front of judge lewis
caplan ultimately it's up to him to
decide if this document changes the
civil case or if it progresses and
potentially we see we see a trial in the
autumn
joe pike in new york thank you very much